what is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation we got ourselves a trailer for Zack
Snyder's Rebel Moon one of his biggest passion
projects finally being brought to life which was
originally pitched to be a Star Wars project
but now it's just gonna be his own precious
Trilogy baby John how are you for at least the
Snyder Awards yes that is what is happening
right now ladies and Gentlemen please go ahead
leave a like on this video and it's a Netflix
trailer they don't we got an ad let's run that
ad thank you to our marvelous sponsors Amazon
and scopely because we're going to be talking
about Marvel strike force today people yeah
look at the background now I've done my time
in the trenches with this game look at this
raw footage let me tell you it's as addictive
as Tony Stark's caffeine habit you'll feel like
Doctor Strange bending reality assembling a
mix of your favorite Marvel characters into
one unbeatable Squad in my lineup I've got the
PowerHouse Luke Cage the web slinging Spider-Man
the Relentless Punisher the deadly Elektra and
the ever essential most underrated Shield Nick
my latest recruit crossbones wouldn't have seen
all the symbiosis of their powers in the 5v5
battles it's like watching The Avengers
assembling all over again a personal MVP
obviously Spider-Man because let's face
it with great power comes a whole lot of
butt kicking I thought I would rhyme but didn't
Marvel Strike Force isn't just about the thrill
of the battle no it's a game of chess with
an Infinity Gauntlet I see what I did a tough
level is your Thanos and figuring out the right
character upgrades and skills to rely on is your
end game and listen up Webheads with an Android
make your move through the Amazon app store it's
like finding a tesseract of deals you get 20
off in-app purchases for Marvel Strike Force
and Amazon coins some more bang for your buck
assemble your ultimate Squad unlock characters
like the regenerating degenerative Deadpool
the enigmatic Venom the Star-Spangled Captain
America The Genius billionaire playboy flat the
rest of Iron Man hey don't forget the shield
medic and many more and stand as Earth's Mightiest
Defenders click on the link in the description box
to download Marvel Strikeforce from the Amazon App
Store and type head first to no action under Roost
[Music]
oh man he's got his composer back do you
know the story of the princess Issa no
wow in myth she was called the Redeemer
so illustrious said this child
would stop the madness of War wow
that she was too Usher in a new age of peace
and compassion that's Anthony Hopkins oh yeah
the world I will never
give that bird
glove for a child
I could not see this feels like
pure Innovation man oh yeah
so freaking Epic what do you think they want
everything I found her that screen Corey stole
I am child of War it's taught that love
is weakness this feels like Zack Snyder
incarnate oh yeah this is left to his own devices
yes
Sif look at this price to
pay for your defiance Wowie
damn one moment I do love this part hold
on anime epic sci-fi all encompassed in one
is that a Charlie Hunter too yep
creature designs and the Aesthetics are amazing
first man Buckbeak
it's also like a Pure Fantasy look at this man
oh yeah it's got a little bit of everything he's
done so far and more oh yeah I know that's
all the combinations and a man can fail
remember
also got that uh Insurrection
Uprising yeah Rebellion
yeah baby
die for what you believe
he also was a cinematographer for this movie
okay yeah all right Army of the Dead this is his
when they say Visionary director
Zack Snyder this is truly a visionary
child of fire on the scar Giver oh my God oh yeah
and he also yeah it's had this project in mind for
like 20 years sure 20 minutes ago good yeah I mean
in a way this almost looks like a like a sucker
punch 2.0 not in spirit not in direct aesthetic
but in the way that it's just like everything
Zack Snyder crammed into one movie except you know
post all the DC experiences now you know yeah yeah
um that looks beautiful that looks better than
most movies that are coming to the movie theaters
that's a trailer man like nothing like a Zack
Snyder trailer yeah I haven't seen Sucker Punch
but I get what you're getting it yeah you'll
see that trailer and you're like this is just
all this stuff that's the only Zack Snyder film I
I have yet to catch um so you've seen the elves uh
that is the uh there's two Zack Snyder movies I
have yet to catch well we'll play a new reaction
before this comes out when we are riding that SEO
train come December 20th 23. uh but yeah I thought
this was an absolutely beautiful trailer you can
see the Star Wars Inspirations the the the pieces
of history that he absolutely adores also his
like obsession with uh human anatomy as well but
also the different creature designs and the the
wonderful Ensemble that is here Tom hulkenberg I
believe is is that his name txl yeah he he who did
the you know he was a composer for of course Zack
Snyder's Justice League uh and then some Army of
the dead as well and now he's back here this is a
this is like a pure passion project brought
to life and even though I said part one and
part two I believe that this is supposed to be a
Trilogy as well and also expanding this universe
into being a graphic novel on top of that game
yeah and the video game as well so there's so
much that they they want to do here and you you
can see it all here on display like like I said
during the reaction this feels very Innovative
uh just it's pure like marvelous creativity at
its finest you know yeah and it looks like it has
a little bit of everything like it's got all that
scopic sci-fi stuff but it also looks like you are
going to spend a good amount of time just like in
the slums of this world too and just looking at it
seems like he's drawn a whole set of societies and
stuff like that and I think that's a fun thing to
do because we've seen him tackle so many expansive
graphic novels that already exist and now this
is him kind of putting all of his interests
again not unlike what I imagine a sucker punch
to be but this feels like so much more thought
out and mapped out it's like it's got elements
of the Rings it's got elements of gladiator it's
got elements of a million Sci-Fi movies you could
think of and even though I'm sure it'll Center on
a particular group of characters it looks like
or a particular character it looks like you've
got kind of a ripley-esque lead as a through
line but you also have this massive Ensemble
and there's so many different design flourishes
and yet they at least as of this trailer feel
like they all kind of coalesce into one world
that I could see how it was Star Wars but it
doesn't feel like it was just scrapped for parts
and quickly repurposed you know it doesn't feel
like the remnants of something that was clearly
that but it does feel certainly inspired by that
kind of thing and yet it also has the Zack Snyder
Edge where it like this feels a bit more dark and
heavy and harrowing than what I Associate's
my word oh I'm so sorry the duplicitousness
The Dread of this world it's kind of boisterous
and it's energy a little bit it was
a matter of working into the Earth
trailer feels a bit edgier than uh you know a lot
of what we've seen out of a Star Wars so it feels
like you're still getting that gritty you know
like the same way his comic book films are sort
of adult it feels similar to the Star Wars it's
like it's an adult version I mean people often
chalk up Zack Snyder's work to something that in
the most implicit terms of being very dark and
this actually provided you know I could see how
this was once a Star Wars pitch because this is
all about you know fighting oppression it's called
Rebel moon for crying out loud and it's space it's
Space Opera so yeah it makes a lot of sense and
uh but you do get that that quality especially
Anthony Hopkins narration of like darkness
and coming into the light and the fighting for
what's right I love everything that I saw here
it's really hard to criticize anything honestly
especially knowing that it's going to be a part
one and part two and as we all know Zack Snyder's
work tends to work better the longer the film is
you know like if this was only one movie then I
might be like ah it might get a little undercut it
might be a bit underserved you know even I really
enjoyed Army of the Dead uh but I still felt like
I still have some a little bit more room to grow
especially in terms of like the storytelling
Department you know I still really liked it
but there there were elements that I thought could
have been better fleshed out but knowing this is
a they're going to be releases a part one and a
part two like okay that's the way to do it then
especially when you're dealing with Zack Snyder's
uh voice you know if it was much latitude as you
can now all we can hope for is that by the time
December rolls around that uh everyone involved
with the writing and then the acting uh they get
their their rifle residuals and then they get paid
fairly for this and I believe that this was I I
could be wrong you can correct me I think this
was done for under a hundred million dollars part
one wow like I I think of that I I would believe
it only because of the amount of things he's shot
in like his backyard that you wouldn't be able to
tell he just seems like he's so got the second
hand second like nature of the filmmaking that
yeah he probably knows how to make something look
great and also come in slightly under budget yeah
the artistic merits here are are absolutely
excellent I I guess that the the only thing
that can have me a bit worried is just some other
things that I might have had with some of like I
I love a lot of his films and then there's a lot
of things that I I also share some of the same
opinions on of okay we'll get too caught up in
the visual experience but he communicates a lot
via tone and mood and atmosphere but I I guess
I'm like well if you're going to be a part one
and part two uh we really we're gonna be meeting
new characters so we really gotta get severely
emotionally invested in them if we're going to be
on board for this very epic long journey and uh
yeah so it's not really a criticism of what was
shown here it's not even a criticism it's just a
bit of a of a concern yeah so we'll we'll see
you know like uh I just I just care about that
first and foremost before anything else honestly
because I love all that stuff but before anything
else I care first and foremost of I gotta be on
board for what they're fighting against and the
motivations and all the goals and stuff rather
than just generality of good versus bad I gotta
attach to these characters yeah and I can't be
too Bleak or too over rod It's gotta also have
some Spirit of fun all right guys so what did
you think of the Rebel Moon trailer did you love
the look of it are you excited for it be sure
to subscribe and click that notification Bell
to get notified when uh we will of course we'll
be reacting to it why the hell not gee it's the
one movie we're gonna skip uh now we're gonna
definitely be reacting to it and so keep a look
out for a reaction when this comes out in December
thank you guys so much for being here [Music]